the Joe Rogan experience that's scare
what happened in the training camp
because you're like [ __ ] any other
fights like two or three weeks away you
know you're not gonna be healed so you
go into the fight knowing you're
vulnerable
that happened before I fought Rothwell
he end up knocking me out but before
that - we could week before my last
sparring session Shane Carwin knocked
mean literally cold it's like a we're a
week away and then you coach like Gabby
all right man you shake it off but in
hindsight like why would you guys let me
fight dude why would you let me fight
that well also why Shane Carwin trying
to knock you out so hard that dude hit
so hard he's a guy who didn't get his
day in the Sun either you know he had
that loss to Lesnar where he came out
[ __ ] Lesnar up in that first round but
then he just gassed out he just lost all
his juice he was so so he put up so much
energy trying to stop Lesnar
so much much so much he just [ __ ]
gonna stop that fight too easily gonna
stop that fight and not to hurt Dean and
they were both champions he was the
interim champion Frank yeah yeah a
crushed Frank Mir with a ruthless series
of uppercuts remember he held him with
one arm and Spartan with the others
corner [ __ ] dude [ __ ] dude that was
terrifying that was with Shane Carwin
was he was at his peak he was starching
Peter in there before that he starched
gay brokens on one punch after he had a
broken nose cuz I broke his nose [ __ ]
his nose up yup
Shane pop down with Shane hit was four
six inch right hand cool story like this
Mike show you lights out and then how
about Gonzaga and Bigfoot Silva fought
bare knuckle that's how they're doing
sir they found a bare knuckle and
Gonzaga piece big Silva you know it's
hard to watch not good big Bigfoot Silva
was a guy that when they made him get
off the test remember that that was the
rudest thing ever because they also
don't fight if you have to have that
stuff the money he needed the money no
I'm saying like if you like you remember
him on TRT
your he was such a nightmare he was
crushed fatal a huge dude crushed
phaidor
remember that a fatal went for ankle
economy just isn't
and faders like hugging on his big toe
he's going like this yeah I'm like
[ __ ] up fader I [ __ ] up you let a
guy get on everything
you literally fight a giant yeah also
the nice guy in the world super nice guy
but how about I was training with him
and they had a real reason to take tests
when you take him off of it he had an
operation on his pituitary gland he had
a tumor yeah hit a tumor that was
thought I mean he was literally
producing too much growth hormone that's
that's why you become a giant like that
so then he has this tumor removed and
now his body's not producing anything
right so he has to take stuff but they
say he can't take stuff so he's just
sick all the marrows fight against Mark
Hunt when he was on TRT and they just
went back and follow that's like a
heavyweight fight of all time afterwards
that's a nice shot yeah
he doesn't hide how about I trained with
Bigfoot to get ready for Big Nog and I
didn't know they were like best friends
and I'm training with him like this
guy's great
next day I'm like where the [ __ ] is
Bigfoot I see a picture him on Instagram
with Big Nog oh boy so he went to test
you out I just think he came in and was
like he was the same guy no he was
training there and I don't think it was
any like bad intention I think he was
like alright yeah if you want to train
go ahead do top of phaidor when he
mounted fader I was like holy [ __ ] that
picture of Jude a giant on top of this
kind of fat Russian dude he was a he was
a building he was like a building
planted on his chest like you're not
shaking that off DC 300 pounds
vert and DC fought him and I go dude you
[ __ ] him up because how can he miss
how can you miss he goes that's easiest
fight in the world how do you miss I
still won shoot they both let his head
like this smile and when you catch a guy
to like where you catch him in his
career and all in like what kind of
testing are we talking about that's the
reality of like a meme MMA pre you SATA
is all when you catch them in what kind
of testing
[Applause]